well this isn't the first time i'm not
yeah don't give me too much credit on
the history thing i've made history for
a lot worse but uh but yeah it's been
it's been quite a few years
um since vince gill hosted
but i you know i'm honored to be asked
and you know i've always i've hosted
stuff and even with lionel and katie i
always have
them to throw to so when you're hosting
by yourself
like if you want to
go off prompter and kind of go off the
script a little bit you can because
you're in control
of your whole moment you don't throw
your you don't you don't start throwing
your co-host under the bus so i'm
excited to be out there and be relaxed
and have fun with the fans and the crowd
awesome can't wait to see you in vegas
that residency we can't wait
yeah i mean we're excited about vegas um
i've always i grew up listening to elvis
vegas album and i always said one day
i'd like to stand up there like elvis
and
just you know croon and sweat
and uh but just that not some of the
other stuff
exactly congrats luke thanks again thank
you megan from inside edition you're up
all right so yeah luke ryan is still
doing his virtual world hey luke so you
just mentioned vince gill and we've had
so many amazing people host in the past
brad cary reba i'm curious now as host
if you could go back and tell us the
first time you watched the cmas
what you were thinking and who was
hosting
oh gosh i mean i had to have been you
know the first time i would have been
a very young kid i guess it would have
been back in the barber mandrel days
um
and it was back when yeah
there were like not many channels on tv
it was where you pushed the little brown
box
to you know now i'm really aging and
dating myself but the bottom line is the
cmas were a big family event for my
family i mean we
all of our radios
on our car everything was always on
country music but we never got to really
go see
the performances and we never really got
to go see
people perform live so if we wanted to
see our favorite stars
on stage we had to watch them we had to
watch them on the cmas and on tv
so
so now in this role it's just very
surreal and i'm really just honored to
be
kind of the master of ceremonies of this
this this crazy night country music's
biggest night